so far vaccination has been the only
effective medical response to the
coronavirus
there hasn't been a drug to treat the
disease
now mornu pyrovir is raising hopes that
covet 19 can be cured one existing
medicine after another was tried during
the pandemic none was found to be truly
effective
this time researchers are cautiously
optimistic
could it be the breakthrough treatment
i'm ben fazel and welcome
mol new premier was developed to treat
the flu but caused a sensation when it
was shown to be effective against covert
19. now the world health organization
says it's looking to issue guidance for
its use the u.s company behind the drug
merck known worldwide as msd has applied
for approval in its home country and
says it can make 10 million courses by
the end of the year
it's a small capsule that's raising high
hopes molnu pirovir is the first
potential prescription pill for kovit
19. its manufacturer u.s pharmaceutical
giant merkin company says it's a
particular benefit to unvaccinated
patients with underlying conditions in
trials the drug cut hospitalizations and
deaths by half having a pill that people
can take it home when you know that
they're high risk and they've caught
covid that has the possibility to be
transformational this is one of those
tools in the toolbox that we have just
been lacking so far
since the pandemic began scientists have
been working to develop an antiviral
medicine that patients can take at home
so far the only treatments approved in
the u.s have to be administered
intravenously or by injection they are
also very expensive
virologists warn however that molno
piravir is not a magic bullet although
we're pleased and optimistic about this
drug which is now applying for emergency
use authorization it should not be a
substitute for preventing infection in
the first place which is why we get
vaccines
the u.s drugs authority the fda could
approve the medication in the next few
weeks
just in time before winter accelerates
covid19 infection rates once again
for more let's talk to simon clark he's
a microbiologist at the university of
reading in the uk
tell us what you think about this new
possible
breakthrough treatment
i think it's a very exciting treatment a
very exciting and interesting way of
administering an ability for doctors to
block the virus from replicating and
therefore causing a more severe
infection so we don't have a huge amount
of antiviral medicines compared to sort
of more traditional antibiotics which of
course do not work against
viral infections so this is a a very
exciting very interesting uh new therapy
which should be i would expect useful
against other infections as well
can you tell us exactly how it works how
it manages to block the virus
so when the virus is replicated inside
our cells because our cells
act like mini factories for making new
virus
this chemical introduces changes to the
genetic code and that stops it being
replicated basically
and if you can't produce more genetic
code more genetic material you can't
have more virus
so
that's how it works and like i say i
expect it will work with other things we
hear that it was originally
developed for treatment of flu but i
think it's a it's got potential other
applications as well
what about the time window within which
it has to be applied to the patient i
know it can't be used too early or too
late can it
no they have to have what is called mild
to moderate symptoms um and uh we're not
exactly sure what that means uh but
there is a fairly it seems a fairly
tight window if you if you give it to
somebody too late then they're not going
to be
to be able to benefit from it and if you
give it to them too early that could
cause problems as well
it really does
depend on getting the the timing right
and we've seen that with other
treatments as well the steroid
treatments that we see which also
reduced
the numbers of deaths in intensive care
units quite significantly simon just how
successful has it been shown to be in in
medical trials
oh so in high risk people uh
administered at the right time it
reduces their their risk of death by
about half
so
of course not everybody who
who is high risk is going to die from
clovid 19 and
not everybody who dies from kovid 19 is
high risk if that makes sense so it's
difficult to know exactly
how those numbers will fall but to take
uh or to reduce the risk for that the
highest that the most vulnerable people
by half is a substantial uh chunk to
take out of this um so it's not a silver
bullet it's not a cure but it will save
an awful lot of a lot of lives
and is there enough of it i mean uh
manufacturers are cranking up the
machines will there be enough money
preview to to treat people
uh eventually yes in the short term my
understanding was
that uh a lot of the production had
already been reserved and bought out by
certain countries
of course
merc msd might
might
be able to increase production
substantially and that will mean they'll
be able to supply more people but there
will be huge demands for this
and there will be i suspect a lot of
complaining from some quarters
particularly the developing world that
they don't have access or sufficient
access to this drug is there any way of
of getting around that
well just to produce more but of course
uh the production facilities um the the
the
the substrates the chemicals that go
into making this medicine uh
you know there is only so much of that
available around the world so there are
supply bottlenecks inevitably i would be
very surprised if if merck msd are just
able to turn on the taps and satisfy
everybody's demand in the short term
even if they wanted to which i'm sure
they would but uh life isn't that simple
no it's not
simon uh one last thing looking at the
bigger picture where will this put us in
the fight against the virus uh in in
ending the pandemic
well it will take a substantial number
of people out of death statistics
basically it will mean that it saves an
awful lot of lives but i'll remind you
that over a year ago we hit upon
treating people in intensive care with
dexamethasone that saved about one-third
of people who would otherwise have died
but we still had enormous outbreaks we
still had a lot of people filling up our
intensive care wards right across the
world uh and i don't think that uh this
medicine will in itself stop that from
happening but it will save an awful lot
of lives in itself so what are you
alluding to are there other drugs in the
pipeline that you're hopeful about
there are other drugs in the pipeline
yes and people will be developing things
all the time
but of course this this medicine is not
active not not multificatious in
everybody it needs to be remembered it
is not a guarantee of success it's not a
a really a viable alternative to a
vaccine
simon clark there for us talking about
the effects and the hopes for monu
preview a a very
um a treatment for covert 19 which uh a
lot of people are holding out hopes for
simon clark's a microbiologist at the
university of reading in the uk thank
you for your time
welcome
meanwhile the world health organization
has granted emergency use authorization
to indian drug maker bharat biotech's
homegrown covert 19 vaccine the who's
backing paves the way for co-vaccine to
be accepted in many other countries and
allows india to donate it to the global
kovacs effort
the decision also makes it easier for
indians who've received the jab to
travel abroad
india already granted emergency
authorization in january and it's become
the second most widely used covert 19
vaccine in the country it's the seventh
corona virus jab to win wh o approval
science correspondent derek williams now
and an important question about getting
the covert vaccine
if i already had kovid 19 why should i
get vaccinated
for a simple reason because the evidence
is convincing
that getting vaccinated even if you had
coveted 19
reduces the chances that you might get
it again
scientists have looked long and hard at
whether immune protection is stronger or
more lasting
in those who had the disease or in those
who've been vaccinated and a new
large-scale study published last week by
the cdc in the u.s
seems to have answered that question it
found that unvaccinated people with a
previous infection
were five times more likely to later
come down with covet again than people
who were vaccinated now it's still not
clear how well those results will hold
up over time the probabilities could
change
in the coming months and years for
example if immune protection from
vaccines
ends up waning in a big way but
right now at least it's comforting to
know
that the vaccines that so many of us
have received at least protect us from
infections in the short term
even better than having had covet 19
would
which is why a lot of health care
authorities now also encourage people
who had the disease and recovered to go
ahead and get vaccinated anyway
in some countries they recommend both
shots post-infection
in others they recommend just one shot
getting vaccinated after recovering even
appears to provoke a turbocharged immune
response that researchers are calling
hybrid immunity or or super immunity
because
those people have extremely high levels
of the antibodies
that protect against the virus
and just a day after the us approved
coronavirus vaccinations for kids aged
between 5 to 11 they've started getting
the jab like here at a school in ohio
where pupils have been receiving
pediatric doses of the bayern tech
pfizer vaccine along with superhero
badges and some snacks
while the risk for children is much
lower than for other age groups they can
still spread the virus so with infection
numbers growing increasing the number of
people who are vaccinated is key to
slowing the pandemic
the u.s territory of puerto rico is
going to a step further and saying the
jab will be mandatory for school
attendance
nice to have you along stay safe and see
you again soon bye-bye
[Music]
you